Andrew Rothstein been with black rock
for about 14 years gonna be presenting
work that's not solely my own my
esteemed colleagues are in the audience
I got forest thanks I'm Fang and David
Durst who have done the majority of the
heavy lifting on this project that I'm
going to probably take more credit than
is due for so here's our contact
information where I run the advanced
data analytics team within Blackrock
solutions within our financial modeling
area and we're definitely recruiting
recruiting data scientists data
engineers generally smart people I think
it's important to understand before we
launch into what we've built why it's
awesome I think it's important to
understand who we are and why we're
doing what we're doing so Black Rock is
the world's largest ask that manager and
I've listed here are our mission
statement to create a better financial
future for our clients our mission ask
the question then of who are our clients
and you'd be either surprised run
surprised to find out that almost
everybody is a client of ours our
clients are our folks with capital
looking to invest looking to earn
returns to meet their financial
objectives we broadly classify I broadly
classify our clients into three
categories institutional clients so
these are banks pension funds who have
lots of capital that they need to grow
in order to meet future liabilities we
tell clients so financial advisors you
meet people who are planning for their
retirement and then in the solution
space or what we call solutions
Blackrock solutions in fact is the
division that we come from within
Blackrock we offer advisory services and
special situation services so if you
think about a lot of the stresses of
2008 2009 and and subsequent Blackrock
was on the other end of the bat phone
when bad stuff was happening so a lot of
the
a lot of the innovation that we that we
put forth we're using to help clients
both plan for their futures in good
times as well as bad I included a link
to our our core values which I think are
I think are important to understand so
first and foremost were fiduciaries to
our clients which means that the capital
that we're investing is other people's
money and it's important to do so when
your when your fiduciary is important to
be responsible in the decisions that
you're making certainly passionate about
performance our clients come to us
because they believe that we can earn
them the returns that they so need that
were one black rock that were
collaborative environment and certainly
core value and so far as its abused in
the in the world today is we're and
we're certainly consider ourselves
innovators okay so I listed the slide as
how but I think it's as much a y as it
is a how in order to be responsible
asset manager it's imperative that you
understand the risk that you're taking
on behalf your clients so you have to be
a risk manager we've built over the past
25 30 years a platform for asset
management that we call Aladdin and it's
a combination of software and business
processes that allow us to invest client
money responsibly something that I think
differentiates us from many of our
competitors is that we are first and
foremost risk managers so we view
managing the risks associated with the
investments that you're making on behalf
of a client as tantamount to making
those investments right so we won't we
won't be making investments unless we
can we can develop a deep understanding
of what the payoffs are those what the
expected payoffs of those those
investments are and we're going to be
using quantitative methods to measure
and describe those financial investments
so we're dirt we're definitely in so far
as we're data engineers and data
scientists were also financial engineers
and finance and economy Trish ins the
the assets that we invest in on behalf
of clients over the years have gotten
much more complicated so the challenge
of
financial modelling group is growing
commensurate with the complexities of
the securities that we're investing in
it's also important to understand that
in order to do a good job risk managing
and valuing complex securities you have
to gather data that helps you justify
your position you have to gather data
that helps you model the complexity of
the securities that you're investing in
on behalf of clients so I said here that
their data hungry beasts that need to be
fed and groomed so how do you build a
financial model financial model building
starts with data data data so there's
markets data there's information there's
data about securities and me and the
team that I work on our background is
predominantly in fixed income fixed
income investing so in fixed income
financial fixed ends fixed income
securities financial modeling and often
financial fixed-income assets are backed
by pools of loans so I'll invest in a
bond and that bond will pay me cash flow
corresponding to the performance of a
pool of loans now that pool of loans
behind each one of those loans is going
to be a person right it's going to be a
economic actor so trying to gather data
allows us to garner insight into how
those individual actors are going to
behave and what the financial
consequences of those actions are going
to be is how we do a good job managing
risks so insofar as we can take that
data and then build financial models
this is not an undertaking that can be
done by machines alone it's certainly
enabled and empowered by machines and
machine learning an important facet of
the financial model building process is
is expressing as expressing human
knowledge right is it's it's
understanding what are the what are the
economic drivers of performance and
behavior and expressing those
quantitatively so feature engineering is
my opinion feature engineering is an
intrinsically human human-driven task
that's part of our machine learning data
pipeline and so far as humans are are
participating in the process we need to
make sure we make we need to make sure
that they're doing so optimally that
they're focused on the parts that that
can be done best by humans and we all
have this amazing capability it's our
eyes and they're connected to our brain
and they allow us to detect patterns it
allows it to be insightful they allow us
to to see things and add context and to
develop understanding that can beat them
packaged into financial models and and
share with our clients so we've come up
with this idea of the Bionic financial
modeler so the Bionic financial modeler
leverages technology produce higher
quality financial models and does so by
engineering for large-scale data science
data pipelines so got a lot of got a lot
of data flowing in making sure that
we're harnessing that data make sure
that were iterating that we're building
financial models that were iterating
over our financial models to make sure
that the insight that we hope to garner
that the human interaction the human
component of the data pipeline reflects
human knowledge the development of human
knowledge and that we can do both
quickly right that we can have the
machines go really really fast and then
they can tell us what they can tell us
what the algorithm suggests and we can
learn from that and engineer stronger
features that we can then feed back into
the system more iterations these higher
quality financial models needs deeper
insights into the future so when I think
about my my experiences as a as an
engineer as a software developer got a
bunch of years of Java development
probably more years of C++ development
than I'd like to admit I done a lot of
development with pearl when spark came
on the scene we decided to jump into
Scala to try and figure out what it was
what it was all about
as a cool why is it not cool what are
the challenges what are the
opportunities involved in in pursuing
this language and and we have very
positive things to say about it I often
think now as a scholar and I consider
myself scowl developer I wonder how I
could ever have tolerated the
boilerplate and the ceremony of Java
when in fact that was an improvement
upon the C++ experience that I had right
so Scala is awesome because it allows
for it's a function it's inherently
functional but object oriented
programming language that allows for 66
inked expression of complex data
processing tasks and when you when you
marry Scala with with spark you can
start you can start doing those data
processing tasks at a very high scale
it's got an awesome type in type
inferencing system so it's only once
you've experienced the epic fail of a
dynamic programming language with a
thousand developers and thin unit tests
that you can really appreciate the value
of a type-safe language statically typed
language Scala here really schol here
the awesomeness of scala's type type
system is that you don't really feel it
the thing that I've always found kind of
crappy about java's type system is its
is it so pedantic it's so it's so
verbose it requires so much ceremony and
the type inferencing system within Scala
really allows us to write six cinq bits
of code that are in fact type-safe spark
spark as a as a skeleton one when i
think of spark as a scala dsl so spark
really allows you to express big data
pipelines it allows you to express big
data pipelines without without leaking
without without the the distributed data
processing engine without its
abstractions leaking that badly on to
your code which which i think is super
awesome
so it allows us to really manage
complexity to do so scalable we are all
dupe developers again you gotta you have
to understand what it's like to manage a
data pipeline of tens to hundreds of
Java MapReduce jobs before you run
screaming with your hair on fire towards
anything that looks better we did a
whole bunch of work with Apache pig as a
DSL on top of job on that produced in
our in our anger and and Scala and spark
have really together offered us a a
really pleasant solution to the
challenge of writing scalable complex
big data pipelines succinctly with
minimal boilerplate we're really excited
about the the distributed data
primitives that are that are arising in
the in the spark community around things
like data frames you know the rdd
concept the resilient distributed data
frame data frames proper and the sparks
equal component that sits on top of them
you got to remember we're finance nerds
here so a good majority of the people
that are in our in our blast radius are
going to be give me sequel or give me
death so this is a real great way for us
to to innovate and not drop all the rest
of the people that we want to bring
along for the ride and we're really
excited about the prospects of doing
more lower latency stuff with spark
streaming and a lot of the financial
modeling that we had been doing prior to
MapReduce was done was done with with
our and sass & S Plus so spark our
function is going to function as a great
bridge for some of our older school
financial modelers and econometricians
to get them onto the next great thing so
when we think about building data
pipelines and doing data science here
are some of the things that I really
really want to switch I really really
want us to bake into our solutions it's
got to be fast it's gotta hide
complexity right it's gotta hide
ceremony it's got to be pleasure to
program in it's got to be visual right
it's got a its got a tickle our visual
stimulator it's got a tickle our optic
nerve right because that's a really
really awesome and powerful thing as
humans that we have and it's got to be
this virtuous cycle of human knowledge
development augmented and enriched with
machine learning the bionic financial
modeler that's what we aspire to okay so
I'm going to talk a little bit about two
different two different components that
we've that we've either contributed to
or or built out and and released in the
open source community first we're going
to talk about the human-computer
interface so we're going to talk a
little bit about visualizing high
dimensional data sets and a cool tool
that we've put in place that allows us
to again tickle that optic nerve and
then we're going to focus on a a project
that we released in the open source
called the SBT spark submit plugin which
allows us as developers to to develop
and deploy spark jobs more quickly and
with less cognitive dissonance so most
people in the audience probably have
heard of like the V is the big V the V
is a big data actually I should I should
say so this work the work of this
segment is from my esteemed colleague
David Durst and I need to channel his
excitement so I big data and so can you
right so when we talk about Big Data
there's the three or four vs depending
on who you talk to the ones that we're
going to focus on in and in our area of
Finance that are our biggest cross to
bear our volume of data so we tend to
have lots of tens to hundreds of
gigabytes to maybe even terrible
single-handle terabytes of a borrower or
of loan performance data and we want to
create an environment where a financial
model or an econometrician can can
consume that data and and garner
insights interactively right so we want
it to be really really quick so we think
about our goal goal of any data
scientists or anyone building a data
science pipeline is really to collect a
ton of data about what's happened in the
past to develop intuition for what
you're seeing in that data to formalize
your knowledge about what's happened in
the past to build a cartoon or a model
for what you think the underlying
phenomena process is and then to
ultimately build some awesome financial
model that tells the future suits their
right to make some high-quality
predictions so the components that that
we're stirring in technically into our
solution are are you know it's a big
part of our legacy spark a huge part of
the the big data the big data
awesomeness that we want and then html5
and d3 in order to take the these
forecasts and bees and there's this
knowledge that we want to garner from
data and presented visually to allow
folks interact with it so garnering
intuition to have to build tools that
help garner intuition they need to be
visual right and they need to be
quantitative so really what we're trying
to do in so far as were we're presenting
data to you is we want to take very
large volume of data trying to still it
down into features that we think are
fine and that financial features that we
think are relevant to the model building
process and we want to present them to
our users and offer an interactive
experience where where users can really
dig in and try to build hypotheses for
what a model what a good model would or
should be should or would be
and the second part we're going to focus
on is once you got a model how do you
know if that model is any good right how
do you how do you know if the model
produces accurate forecasts how do you
know that models something you're
willing to invest upon so a model that
and again this is part of the dream so
we gets a lofty things like a model that
automatically produces accurate
forecasts and business users can
leverage to make educated decisions
about the future so when we think about
it as like an intellectual pipeline
these are the different stages that were
predominantly focused upon so here's the
reality of what what we rolled up to in
2012 2013 right and as a data scientist
really wow it's a ripple or as a
software engineer you're like wow it's a
red bull that's amazing that's awesome
language is complex ask Allah with a rep
ball it's like C++ with a red bow wow
that's amazing and then all the economy
Trisha's have left already call the
finance people have left already so we
need to figure out a way to put a
happier more interactive face on the on
the stuffs that we're building
so one thing that we built that we have
not yet open sourced although I don't
see any reason why we wouldn't figure
out a way to carve out the open source
of all parts of it is a system that we
called da Vinci as a as an our developer
as a SAS developer the first thing you
do after you get your data frame is you
run whatever the analogous routine is
for summarize right give me all my
univariate statistics on every column of
my data frame and if you're really
enterprising give me some by various
statistics right show me how individual
features correlate with each other so we
did is we built a system with spark that
takes an arbitrary data frame and
renders universities brenda's visual
univariate statistics over each of the
columns of the data frame as well as
something we're not showing here which
is bivariate statistics so you can you
could see a correlogram and and you can
sort of try to experience that the ways
in which the features are interacting
something that was a little bit more
visual or a little bit more interactive
than da Vinci that that already existed
in the open source is this idea of a
scatter plot matrix so what we did here
what we did here was we we connected the
spark job server which is something I'm
going to go into a little bit of detail
about 2 to a d3 implementation of a
scatter plot matrix which will allow us
to explore and interact with potentially
very high dimensional data try again
build that intuition for what's going on
in this very high dimensional data space
that I need to start building financial
models with so we could not show so we
we have two versions of this one that's
on premise that I'm going to show that
has a mortgage data set inside of it and
another that's that's running on ec2
right so the spark job server and all
the work that we've done on the spark
job server has been committed back to
the community
and the ec2 example you can spin up for
yourself and/or plug in your own data
sets the ec2 data set is going to show
some airline data and the hour on Prem
demo is going to show a mortgage data
set ok let's see so here's the here's
the airline data so if I could orient
you to the UI it's essentially a
collection of features right it's a very
very big data frame and you get to pick
which of the features you want to render
in the scatter plot matrix at each row
and column is essentially a scatter plot
of feature X versus feature y so along
the diagonal you sort of seeing a
histogram some form of histogram along
the diagonal another thing we've added
in here was we did k-means clustering on
the whole data set so that the coloring
and the coloring of the corresponding
dots correspond to the class of the
class in the k-means clustering so we
did for K equals 6 and so this is our
scatterplot matrix now with what's
really cool about scatterplot matrix is
not just that you can see this this by
itself is not really I mean it's cool
it's interesting it's insightful the
colors really add add to the experience
but I think makes it really really
awesome is this concept of brushing and
linking so each of the data points
exists in all the different dimensions
and they're connected so it's really
important to be able to say like for
instance the arrival delay so you're
going to have a collection down here of
of observations that correspond to small
but nonzero delay and it's interesting
to see where in the other dimensions in
this very high dimensional space where
do those other points appear
and what's more as I as I move as i move
my window it's interesting to see where
my points are migrating to in all the
corresponding other dimensions now I'm
sure if I knew more about the airline
business I could spin you a tall tale of
how amazingly intuitive in Austin this
is I don't know all that much about this
underlying data set so I'm going to try
and switch to a data set that I know
much more about which is our mortgage
data set another important thing to
recognize is that in order to render
this visualization right we're talking
behind this data set behind what you're
seeing here are depending on the data
set tens to hundreds of millions of
observations and to do that brushing and
linking with hundreds of millions of
observations we haven't yet figured out
how to make it make it interactive right
so what we're essentially doing is
sampling down we're taking a random
sample of anywhere from a hundred to a
thousand points depending on your on the
power of laptop to try and again build
intuition for a subset of the data and
if you you we also added this notion of
resample so if you want to let's go back
to this one if you want to get another
random sample of the data it says
straightforward as clicking a button and
waiting and praying the demo gods are on
your side okay so in our mortgage data
set so now this is a little bit more
applied in the financial modeling space
so on behalf of our clients we vested
mortgage-backed securities those
mortgage-backed securities are backed by
a pool of mortgage loans each one of
those mortgage loans we know a whole
bunch of features about the loan and or
the borrower we're know the borrower's
name we don't we don't know any
personally identifiable information but
we know a bunch of facts about stuff
that showed up on their own mortgage
application
and facts about the property the
underlying property that's functioning
as the collateral behind the loan so
it's really important when we're
building financial models for how these
secure how we think these securities are
going to perform to understand what the
behaviors of those underlying borrowers
are going to be contingent on a forecast
say of the macroeconomy we think rates
are going to rise for the Great's are
going to fall how is that going to
impact borrowers what are the decisions
borrowers are going to make and what are
the financial consequences of those
behaviors so some of the typical and
important features that you'll get in a
mortgage and a mortgage data set our
fight coats the credit score of the
borrower the rate that the borrower is
paying is rate olt be the original loan
to value ratio so how much money did you
borrow versus how what was the value of
the property at the time that the loan
was originated DTI is a debt to income
ratio so a direct measure of ability to
pay and we did it again we did a k-means
clustering on this and you can see that
sort of the the the pink cluster is a
very interesting cluster it corresponds
to loaf aiko's right so these are the
the more credit constrained let's take a
look at them by themselves
they tend to have L TVs all over the
place they tend to have debt to income
ratio focused right in the middle they
tend to have balances unfortunately our
balance line sort of gets cut off here
that the underlying data set that we're
using here is a public data set from
from Freddie Mac so Freddie Mac's one of
the big government-sponsored entities
that pool mortgage loans and these are
this is a this is a data set of very
high credit quality borrowers in the
balance space in order for you to be
eligible for a for a Freddie Mac alone
you need to borrow depending on the area
you live in you need to borrow
essentially less than four visit it's
called the conforming limit so you need
to be borrowing less than four hundred
seventeen thousand dollars and that's
sort of like the this implied horizontal
line on the balance screen in the LTV
space there's often a cut at 80 points
right because again the the standard
loan is for less than a dl TV once you
go over atl TV once you're borrowing
more than eighty percent of the value of
the property all sorts of other complex
things kick in for you so what i really
like to do when i'm looking at these
data sets is sort of what i did what i
did with the airline data set which is
to try and get a feel for how get a feel
for how as i move over a distribution of
one variable how that impacts the
distribution of other variables again
the try and remember when the business
of trying to build financial models that
are going to predict and that are going
to forecast how these borrowers are
going to behave based upon what we know
about them and this represents what we
know about them
so now how do we do it how do we do it
how do we do all this awesomeness so the
spark job server is a is a component
that we used in order to build spark
enabled web applications one of the
challenges in the spark framework is
that all of your data frames are tied to
a single spark context that that's
running in your driver program and your
your data frame your data frame can hit
disk and it can survive the run of a job
that way but if all you have is a handle
to a data frame all you have is a handle
to a data frame in your program exits
then that data frame goes poof so the
spark job server is long is a long
running process that essentially
embodies the spark context so you can
create data frames that are sort of
long-lived and you can interact with
them in restful ways so we reference
here on this on the slide we reference
the spark job server it's available on
github and all of the demos although the
airline demo all the infrastructure for
the airline demo excuse me has been
contributed back and you can you can
take a look at that yourself in general
the idea is that you deploy your your
web server your spark server you can
build your job the code that corresponds
to your job you can upload the code that
corresponds to your job to the spark
server via post request and then you can
interact with the assorted classes that
represent your your spark jobs or your
spark tasks via restful api with ajax
in the slides here we have we have the
instructions for replicating the
external version and also instructions
for how you would go about replicating
this on promise for yourself okay so the
next part I'm going to talk about is
trying to do this more straight through
from an engineer's perspective right
building a data pipeline amounts to
writing it's on a code building that
code deploying that code and making sure
that when you run that code you run it
in a way consistent with what you're
expecting right a lot of these stages in
your pipeline are going to be
parametrized than you you want to make
sure that when you build your data
pipeline and your hand at the bob right
handed the Sally that Sally can
replicate your work right and there's
all these settings along the way that
you're going to want to convey to Sally
and best way to do that is to figure out
a way to get them into version control
right so a big part of building straight
through spark analytics is taking the
the deploy and run stages codifying them
as code in your in your project so we
what we built here so first now now we
have to understand like the environment
in which were operating here so this is
what people think we do right the
minority report where we're waving our
hands and data frames are flying hither
and yon and we're masters of the
universe with the with jacked into the
into the matrix right when the reality
is probably something a little bit more
like this right where we're doing a lot
of hard work right staring at code
debugging debugging complex data
pipelines debugging distributed systems
I'm sure everybody realizes bugging
distributed systems not like there's
naught to X difficult debugging though
Ananse tributed system it's more like 10
or 50 X complicated so we need to make
sure that again though we're codifying
the way in which our applications are
being wrong
so here's the canonical example of why
MapReduce is so awesome right it's the
way you it's the way you explained
MapReduce to people who have never who
haven't read the paper right and in and
of itself each one of these stages
relatively straightforward but when
taken together amounts to a really
complex data complex distributed data
processing engine so we need to make
sure that again we're building tools
that help us meet the complexity of of
this challenge in a reasonable way so
when when MapReduce came out when Google
published their paper I closed the close
of the link i found the the original
presentation Jeff Dean the Dean game wat
presentation and they're talking about
MapReduce and it's super duper awesome
and they talked about how easy it is
right it's easy it's really easy because
of all the complexity of the underlying
distributed system the GFS or the HDFS
bit that's all hidden from you right the
scheduling of your mappers in a data
locale a we're way that's hidden from
you getting you know employing thousands
to tens of thousands of machines right
starts feeling a little bit more like
that Minority Report view of what we do
but you have fun you have the
perspective of where they were sitting
right this is much easier but it's much
easier compared to what the alternative
was without it right so here word count
is super easy so here's the canonical
example of word count coded in java
right so it's easy but it's only easy
because what was done before it was so
unbelievably hard right now we've gotten
spoiled this is no longer easy right
this is no longer this is no longer
straightforward and also mapreduce sort
of suffers from this it suffers from
this latency concern where in between
each one of your each one of your jobs
your data is hitting the disk right and
that means that the throughput that
you're getting is not going to be great
if you're trying to do trying to do
things iteratively right a lot of your
machine learning exercises are our
convex optimizations where you're
hypothesizing a model and then you're
testing that model and then you're
updating the parameters or your model
based on the residuals right so
inherently you're doing guess that model
fitme you know guess that parameters for
model compute residuals update model new
guests estimate residuals new gas
estimate residuals and if you're hitting
the disk in between each one of those
stages you're certainly doing something
that wasn't doable before which is
awesome but you're incurring a ton of
i/o at each stage of that pipeline it's
kind of stinky right so it allows you to
it allows you to go wide as you get a
tremendous amount of bandwidth right it
allows you to get all of those disks in
your data center spinning and munching
on data but it also makes all of those
disks in your data center spin and munch
on data which kind of stinks so we do
big data but we do it very slowly right
waiting for those jobs to finish spend
the ton of time waiting for those jobs
to finish and that's not really the kind
of interactive experience that we want
we want it to be interactive and quick
so that you don't lose your train of
thought I thought this was a good idea
and here was my test and it was either a
good idea and not a good idea now what's
my next three ideas that I want to try
so spark really was an awesome turning
point for us because it allowed us to do
these
more machine learning iterative data
pipelines in a way that you didn't incur
disk i/o at each iteration of your for
example your convex optimization right
and it's also super succinct as I was as
I was talking about in the beginning of
the presentation so here is it's
definitely not as full featured as the
five pages of Java code that implemented
word count but it's it's succinct it is
it's simple and it's straightforward and
you don't you don't need to have a
thousand hours of Scala under your belt
to understand what's going on here right
and I have so this is this came off of a
spark web page and this this table here
sort of shows how if you're working on
stuff that is iterative in nature how
it's a total game changer for you terms
here in terms of your latency so if
happy and productive data scientists but
wait now we have a new problem right
you're doing when you're doing
performance you doing profiling of your
application and the component of your
application that super duper SLO bubbles
up to the top and everybody you know
jumps on it and fixes it what happens
next I think that was number two on the
list becomes number one on the list
right so the jobs are running quickly
but there's a ton of burnt time from a
developer's perspective in making sure
that you got your spark submit command
correct right and making sure that I
want to run it on this cluster versus
that cluster I want to run it for our k
equal six I want to run it for K equals
13 making sure that you're getting all
of the details correct correct and you
know we aspire to be detail oriented
people and make sure that we're getting
all of the characters typed correctly
into the terminal but there's definitely
a better way
so it wouldn't be a good presentation
without next case CD comment creo so
when you think about the stages of
submitting your your of submitting your
your skull application is essentially a
disability well there's a code stage is
a test date the code build tests right
and you're going to be doing that whole
bunch but then there's a package deploy
run part of the pipeline and that
involves typing up a whole bunch of
characters into the terminal so what we
set out to do is to try and capture more
of that in in version control and and
hide a little bit of the complexity
around submitting spark applications so
that you can get back to focusing on
your on the contents your data pipeline
and not on the operational aspects of it
so to to augment here's the a simple
example of a spark application so a
spark application that computes pie
statistically right and here are the
sparks submit commands that you need to
type into your terminal easy peasy right
although each one of them is probably
about on a 150 200 characters gotta make
sure you get it right so these commands
are I view these commands is difficult
to remember and no real easy way before
the work that we've done to sort of
store them so the first idea is bash
right bash the rescue vast will save us
so we'll start writing bash scripts and
bash allows you for allows you to
generalize certain parts certain parts
of the sparks submit which is super
duper helpful bash scripting rocks right
and now you've got your collection of
you got your scholar program and you got
your collection of bash scripts that you
need to pet and make sure stay
functional and operational right so
bashes bash is great for getting started
bash to me is like Excel it's one of
those one of those great things to get
get you from zero to one really really
quickly but to go from like one to 100
really really hard right and sometimes
you wish you hadn't gone from zero to
one with it because getting from 12
hundred is probably more difficult than
going from zero to hundred with a better
solution right so some of our challenges
around bash scripting included no
environment isolation making it
repeatable bash is not great at at
abstraction encapsulation right you can
does really have the notion of modules
you can include scripts from scripts to
set environment variables and it's
inherently not it's not really types of
language right you can type whatever you
want it to your script them and it
bounced out at runtime so these are just
a small facet of a much larger of much
larger challenges right of what we're
about really trying to achieve here we
want to be able to do we want to be able
to build lots of different spark
applications right we want to be able to
codify the way in which they're deployed
in a single application you're going to
have different sub modules and different
components of your application that are
focused on different things have
different dependencies so you don't per
se want to necessarily be pulling in
your H based jars and running your HBase
jar downloads if all you're doing is
building a biz right and also now you've
got the complexity of all the different
ways in which you want to deploy this
thing right this web app this rock
application that you've built so we we
showed deploying to ec2 and we're
running a very big yarn cluster on
premise right so that that single data
pipeline that ran that ran the k-means
clustering on those respective data sets
right you want to make sure that you can
capture how to run them in the different
environments and in a scalable way so
Scala to the rescue
so we did was we built a an SVT plugin
so SBT is the scallop build tool we
built a plug-in that allows you to
specify how jobs are fired so sort of
takes Park submit and hide it behind the
SBT plugin coded in Scala and I'm sort
of running at a time so I'm going to try
and go quickly this this shows how
simple it would be to take the spark by
example and and enable our plug-in with
it and our plug-in will make it so that
you can fire this the spark pi job via
the SBT rebel or at the command line
with just SBT spark pie and if you
wanted to deploy it on the onion in the
yarn mode we have it's a matter of
setting a couple more coding a couple
more settings into your build that SBT
that you'll include in your in your
project VCS right so SBT is a way for
buildings for a little bit more
background SBT is a way for building
skull applications just coated it you
know turtles all the way down is coated
in scala itself so SBT is sort of like a
meta build system it it offers build
system primitives but you can stitch
them together in scala yourself to build
a scala application it offers a bunch of
cool features around build task
parallelism and its interactive so it
allows for fast incremental builds it's
got a really cool continuous integration
mode or continuous testing mode where
you can turn SBT on tell it I want to
run the tests in this I want to run this
collection of tests and as you're
hacking away in your your editor with
each save it sorry running your tests so
if you're into really into test-driven
development it's a great way to do that
with with Scala the fact that the probe
the build tasks and the build system is
coded in Scala mean to get all the
benefits of your UI I mean of your of
your IDE so you get autocomplete we love
J so you get that awesome IntelliJ
experience when you're coding in your
build system as well right it's not like
you have to drop to make and suffer
through you know using Emacs in order to
edit your make file its expense it's
extensible and the reason we included
the slide is because it shows how when
you when you want to submit a task on to
a cluster that perhaps is running on ec2
in order to use spark submit in a
cluster to deploy jobs on a cluster you
have to know who you need to talk to you
need to know who the master which which
note is the master of your cluster and
AWS through their their Java SDK allows
you to interrogate for hosts what's the
host that has this tag so if you set up
your cluster in the appropriate way you
can make it so that people firing jobs
against against that cluster don't need
to again drop drop context and figure
out like what's the what's today's
cluster what's the name of the master
what's the port that the master is
listening on right you can you can
integrate the AWS Java SDK into your
Scala code to hide that complexity from
your user so yeah code compiles now no
errors and it wouldn't be a great
presentation without the world's most
interesting man right and last but
certainly not least we wanted to cover
the fact that this plugin works in multi
project builds so insofar as my single
data pipeline has a ETL components got a
machine learning component it's got a
date of is component you want to sort of
bundle them all together because you're
coding everything in Scala yay it's
important that you be able to define the
various different spark tasks that you
want associated with those individual
modules independently but within this
the context of a single project so this
is something that we that we needed and
we were happy to contribute back into
the community so this this really ties
it all together for us
you know we wanted to we want to want to
be insightful we want to start with
features you want to take advantage of
the optic nerve in our brain to do human
learning to do machine enabled human
learning and we want to make sure that
we're doing it in a really efficient way
and that where we're not wasting time
coding boilerplate and that we're not
wasting time remembering complicated
commands to type into the terminal or
rebel in order to repeat the work of our
peers with that any questions or thank
you for a time far away I'm just curious
how much Blackrock leverages the ML live
and the graphing libraries of spark
another kind of the external libraries
besides just the core spark we want to
leverage them a lot more the the k-means
the example that we did in here with
k-means that was with spark ml our
legacy is very much r & sass so we're
trying to pull our colleagues along
right we're trying to push them into
this new into this new world and it's
challenging
oh I'm curious use the spark submit jobs
to submit the actual jobs to the cluster
but do use anything else but prototyping
like Zeppelin or maybe ipython notebooks
yes yes we try to add Zeppelin right
when they open sourced it and it it's
exactly what we want it's exactly what
we want we're super excited but the
experience is not really there yet but I
think that that's going to be the way in
which we take our our SAS & R R and rs
plus colleagues and we convince them
really get them over the line to say
like look we're offering an interactive
experience all of the complexity of this
system is really hidden from you in so
far as that's that's that same
complexity is hidden from you in those
tools so we're really super duper
excited about I can't I can't say enough
positive things about it I really want
it to be awesome and the experience just
hasn't hasn't been awesome yet
I actually my coach is going to be about
the financial financial part of your
presentation sure you mentioned you are
doing this clustering and trying to
predict the behavior of different debt
holders right yeah mortgages I don't
know that multibuy securities there are
pool full of debts and investor can get
some tranch and expect some return from
it right so what you here try to predict
you try to predict the default right
default of the there there Mulder there
are a bunch of different behaviors that
the individual borrowers will perform
that have consequences the cash flows of
the securities that are created from
them so certainly concerned about credit
right but you're also actually very
concerned depending on which investments
you're making you're also very concerned
about people refinancing their mortgages
if I lend you money I lend you money at
six percent and mortgage rates rally
down to four percent I'm going to get
the money that I lent you back it's
going to be a prepayment right because
you're going to refinance down to four
percent so now I had an expected income
stream from you at six percent over 30
years and now the best i can do is four
percent over 30 years right it's not a
realized loss but it's an unrealized
loss right because i was hoping to earn
that higher yield from you over over
that same time period so that's a
decision that a borrower will make that
will have consequences to me as an
investor so really what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to get the full story of
what are the potential behaviors for the
borrower and then what are those what
are the financial consequences of those
decisions that those borrowers have to
make on the investments that I've made
on behalf of my clients okay so what's
your goal here if you try to understand
you're going to just advise your clients
where to put their money or you
make your bits on the moves so we're
investing it's not our money it's our
clients money and our clients have
financial objectives and we're taking
their capital and we're deploying it on
their behalf by investing in securities
we invest client money and
mortgage-backed securities so we need to
make sure that the security is that
we're picking on their behalf we need to
make sure that we understand at least we
have an expectation of how those
borrowers are going to perform in the
various different scenarios of what we
think the market is going to look like
right I see so you missed your clients
money and you want to return give them
as had returned as you can and you get
your fees from that okay correct
um what what format are your end users
actually accessing this data after it's
been through these spark transformations
is it in HDFS itself and they're writing
like pythons Park against it or is it in
like a relational database both and more
right the UI that we present here the
davinci you I that we put that that we
presented and that and have deployed on
premise they're using that in order to
do first round inspection and intuition
building around the data set tryna again
da Vinci is really not about model
building Perseids about understanding
distributions of individual features to
allow you to engineer complicated
features that you think are meaningful
the the machine learning part of the
pipeline to this gentleman's question
where we aspire to make it more spark ml
like to allow us to do it at scale
currently it's very much are so will do
will it will with in partnership with
someone who's more of an our hacker will
come up with a feature set that we want
to include in a model estimation well a
plot will extract will generate an
extract that's got the feature the full
feature set will write that to the HDFS
or we've developed the strong love love
for parquet so we'll write that as a
bunch of parquet files and will allow
them then to sample down from there to
create an extract that they could load
into our to do some sort of convex
optimization right so that's how we sort
of and that's why we're so super duper
excited about spark are because we feel
like right now in our data pipelines
it's a little bit seemed and it involves
a little bit of hand off and that
handoff creates problems so making it
more straight through hopefully will
will allow us to you know iterate more
quickly so I guess how often do you go
from selecting features to refining your
model do you do it on a weekly basis
daily month
the we aspire to do it more quickly than
we do currently I'd say we do a full-on
model the estimation we have oh there's
a large family of models are responsible
for so to say that we do that we would
do a new flagship model once every six
months doesn't mean that we're all
working on one model over a six-month
time horizon we aspire to be delivering
models continuously so we're trying to
take the folks that we have dedicated to
financial modeling and sort of divvy
them up to the various different product
types and models that were responsible
for to make sure that we're iterating as
quickly as we can on the whole the whole
Hoover of the whole collection spark the
reason we're so excited about spark is
that it creates the opportunity for us
really to take the data pipeline and run
it on steroids right to to really create
and again this was part of the dream
that I may be glossed over i'm on a
little bit too fast on but the dream is
to be able to synthesize features do a
convex model optimization at scale
visualize the new model and give the
roman thumbs up or thumbs down on it and
to do that in the context of minutes to
hours rather than right now it's
definitely more of a days to weeks type
in engagement
okay thanks everyone so it's lunchtime
on the seventh floor and afterwards at
two o'clock back